[Musique]
bienvenue pour cette dernière édition du
7 8 hebdo de la saison édition spéciale
au cours de laquelle nous reviendrons
sur quelques-unes des principales
informations que nous avons développée
sur cette antenne depuis septembre
dernier en compagnie de jean michel
fourgous
bonsoir soit président de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines également
maire les républicains à d'elancourt
voici lé titre au cours de la prochaine
demi heure nous évoquerons entre autres
la ryder cup à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
c'était en octobre dernier bilan de
l'événement et qui ressemblait surtout
une répétition grandeur nature des jeux
olympiques de 2024 attendus eux aussi
sur le territoire de l'agglomération à
les enseignements des européennes de mes
derniers sont connus mais quels seront
les impacts sur les campagnes menées
lors des municipales
éléments de réponse à suivre et puis un
retour également aujourd'hui sur les
principaux événements du monde de
l'innovation à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
nous parlerons automobile aéronautique
mais aussi éducation pourra débuter
jean michel fourgous je vous propose
d'évoquer la ryder cup compétition de
golf par équipes entre les meilleurs
américains les meilleurs européens
événement qui a rassemblé quelques 27
mille visiteurs pour assister à la
victoire de l'europe
première question est ce que vous
estimez que saint quentin en yvelines à
relever ce défi sans quoi que oui
indiscutablement on était un peu inquiet
mais je n'en mets pas toutes les nuits
dans la semaine des riders cup mais
est très inquiet est ce que ça d'être
équilibrés d'abord premièrement
économiquement il ya 200 ans 35 millions
de retombées économiques
déjà c'est quand même un sacré succès
qu'on avait complètement sous-estimé
d'ailleurs il ya eu ni deux il est
demandé par la ryder cup par la
fédération française qui évoque ce
chiffre de 235 millions deuxièmement sur
l'attractivité de saint-quentin parce
qu'en fait pour nous qu'on ait des
belles entreprises d'aider beau projet
mais il faut être attractif
aujourd'hui une compétition entre les
territoires pour être interactivement
est-ce que saint-quentin élèves écoutent
et l'effet d'augmentation la notoriété
une fois tout le monde nous connaissait
pas cinq ans demain je vais vous dire
que même aux états unis ma fille ts en
france que ces peuples là et elle voyait
le nom c'est donc c'était assez
impressionnant effectivement le nom de
saint quentin en yvelines plus d'un
milliard de fois cité dans la presse à
genève melissa bon troisièmement relatif
voilà pour saison passée mais les
mauvaises dettes augmentent la notoriété
bien sûr en même temps la fierté
d'appartenance donc du coup à
saint-quentin aussi bien des salariés
que des habitants de saint quentin donc
augmenter la notoriété la fierté
d'appartenance
donc je dirais que on est tous bien sûr
très content donc c'est une belle
réussite et en même temps souvent on me
dit mais quand on voit que vous avez su
gérer un événement de cette dimension
pour la france donc on
on vous propose donc on voit que il ya
beaucoup de projets qui arrive
aujourd'hui sur saint quentin qui sont
liées qui ont qui ont su qu'ils ont eu
enfin l'effet positif de la ryder cup ça
a donné
bien sûr un coût de jeu précis avait
besoin se disent à fonctionner quand
même soit mais indiscutablement la
valeur ajoutée et net sans bavure
on va parler des jeux olympiques puisque
c'est ils vont se gagner comme n'ayant
pas gagné elle n'y avait pas de français
parmi oui m'enfin bon il est alors
épinglé la france
donc voilà on va parler dans un instant
des jeux olympiques ce sera le prochain
rendez vous est ce que c'était une
répétition ou pas on refait un petit
point sur cette ryder cup avec elle ce
reportage que nous avions diffusé en
octobre dernier le golf national de
saint quentin en yvelines est entré dans
une nouvelle dimension et c'est ryder
cup 2018 sa tribune de 6800 places
installé au départ du trou numéro 1
marqué l'histoire de la compétition en
devenant la plus grande infrastructure
jamais construite pour une ryder cup des
frissons des frissons et des fruits sans
un vrai stade de sport un vrai stade de
foot de basket de le stade de france de
golf
c'est vraiment impressionnant c'est
grand déjà et il c'est grandiose
l'ambiance est géniale il ya énormément
nombre il y a des yeux robe qui courent
d'un côté des
ils essayent de l'autre et pan oui c'est
grandiose voilà on peut pas dire que ce
soit pas beau c'est un grand succès
français la tribune ensoleillé ça veut
tout dire ça fait un peu la france
la zone du roi soleil on n'est pas loin
de versailles
le parcours a également été plébiscité
par les supporters et les joueurs des
deux camps préparé pendant plus de deux
ans avant le début de la compétition
pour un coût de 7 5 millions d'euros qui
est aujourd'hui considéré comme l'un des
meilleurs au monde où tant de travail
décent et des sacrifices les voir que
voilà il s'est bien passé
l'image que la france a donné les routes
nationales à rené allemonière s'explique
c'est super c'est super content et je
suis très fier a fait d'aimer cqib et
voilà comment s'est passé le golf
national va maintenant retrouver une
activité plus classique pendant les
prochains mois avant d'organiser une
nouvelle compétition planétaire dans six
ans les jeux olympiques de 2024
et justement ces jeux olympiques on va
en parler un petit peu
l'organisation se met déjà en place oui
alors je rajouterais que saint quentin a
pris fin août seulement une notoriété
internationale vous que c'est très
content c'était un peu surprenant mais
bon donc bien entendu djo rajouter
là-dessus avec quatre sites olympiques
enfin trois à quatre sites olympiques on
a trois sites qui sont validées on
attend que le quatrième notamment sur la
colline des longs cours de l'été soit
validé parce qu'il ya une grande
compétition six ou sept en interne parce
que bon 50 du coût beaucoup de sites
olympiques
toujours des des arbitrages des
concurrents c'est bon mais donc du coup
d'ailleurs du fait ça remet un petit peu
c'est d'y faire on n'aura pas la dite
décision définitive avant 2020 donc on
est on diffère mais sur les projets
qu'on étudiait sur la colline sont
différées du couvent est ce que si ces
six lits à aulla pas bien sûr d'été
c'est pas du tout le monde ya une
dizaine de projets pour repréciser qui
ont été qui ont répondu à l'appel que
vous aviez lancé appel à candidatures il
en restait deux normalement le verdict
était attendu pour ce mois de juillet et
puis là vous nous dites donc
de par la concurrence il faudra attendre
maintenant 2020 pour savoir si
finalement l'épreuve pourra se tenir ou
non sur la colline d'elancourt mais on
se concertera avec tout le monde si donc
c'est bien confirmé il ya quand même
plus d'une chanceux de me faire faut
être prudent sur le mets sur avec toutes
les concertations nécessaires à ce
projet tout cas voilà c'est prêt il
s'effraie il suffit qu'on nous dise
quand même si c'est oui avec le vtt ou
semble t il restera en tout cas verrue
sur piste notamment le golf aussi du bmx
ça ce sera organisée sur saint quentin
en yvelines il ya aussi des compétitions
équestres là ce sera du côté de
versailles
mais sur saint quentin en yvelines
notamment pour le vélodrome vous
réfléchissez déjà à l'organisation à la
circulation aux transports retombées
éventuelles il ya tout un aménagement
qui sera fait mais aussi un effet
secondaire de gio et les radios et
l'europe la rigueur comme on avait testé
un peu la sécurité du futur sans travail
et le jus on a coordonné quand même près
de 3000 caméra avec de drones
un hélicoptère extrêmement équipe est
plus un satellite au secteur que d'un
satellite
demain on verra une pièce de deux euros
vous faut être conscient que le monde a
donc bien entendu tout cela nous a
permis de préparer la sécurité du futur
notamment pour les jo et on a obtenu de
la part du gouvernement
l'attribution donc du commissariat du
futur donc qui sera dans les trois ans
qui va qui va voir donc qui va pousser à
saint quentin pour toute là cet hôtel g
et notamment des jo et qui arrivent en
même temps que j'ai eu et qui sera
installé sur la commune d'hallencourt
bah oui parce qu'on est le comice a le
plus obsolète donc c'est sûr elle en
cours mais c'est le gouvernement qui
avait déjà attribué sa dont kerry un
moment donc voilà c'est tout ça est
confirmée ça c'est une très bonne
nouvelle par contre bien sûr nous allons
continuer à dérouler une partie de
l'actualité de cette année avec vos
actualités locales marquées notamment
par la multiplication des initiatives
pour lutter contre les déserts médicaux
un tout autre sujet si un attrape par
exemple en novembre dernier une maison
de santé était inauguré un reportage un
peu le médical de 285 mètres carrés
répartis sur 3 zones c'est la nouvelle
maison de santé du théâtre de trappes
médecins généralistes sages femmes
infirmières ostéopathe psychologue
orthophoniste un projet collectif et un
travail collaboratif dont par nos
rencontres par nos échanges ne fait pas
de de savoir ce que fait ce que font les
autres et chrétiens
on a une orientation beaucoup plus
efficace ça doit partir des
professionnels et les professionnels à
partir du moment où ils ont un projet
que ce soit dans une maison de santé ou
par une coordination entre eux mais la
rs doit être capable de les accompagner
c'est aussi ça le dialogue entre tous
les professionnels de santé médecins
infirmières ostéopathe sages-femmes
psychologue qui permet une prise en
charge globale des patients c'est ça que
nous voulons encourager coût total de
cette maison de santé près d'un million
d'euros avec un financement de l' agence
régionale de santé de l'ue rps hauteur
de 350 mille euros une subvention de la
région ile-de-france de 260 milles euros
ça correspond à une volonté de la région
la présidente de la région valérie
pécresse est bien de lutter contre les
déserts médicaux il en est ici dans une
ville
qui est l'une des plus carencée en
termes de médecins généralistes alors
naturellement il est important de
soutenir ce type de structure et avec
encore une fois un montant très
importante pour la ville de trappes
classé en zone d'intervention
prioritaire par la rs est une
opportunité d'augmenter l'offre de soins
sur la commune ont cette maison de santé
qui je viens d'apprendre la maintenant
représente 14 praticiens
c'est un pôle essentiel pour notre ville
d'autres pièces vont être aménagés pour
pouvoir accueillir de nouveaux
spécialistes et des internes en médecine
dans cette nouvelle maison de santé et
depuis une autre maison de la santé a
été officialisée sur le secteur de 50
types de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
pardon à montigny le bretonneux en lien
avec la faculté de médecine et ses
étudiants la santé une démission de
l'agglomération est ce que ces déserts
médicaux ça vous inquiète et quelles
initiatives éventuellement
l'agglomération peut mettre en place
aider les municipalités se concerter
avec la rs l' agence régionale de santé
ont subi comme toutes les communes de
france bien sûr cette désertification
qui est extrêmement préoccupante pour
qu'on nous ministre et bien sûr que nous
allons cours un exemple l'or sur 50 1
j'avais tout un plan qui se met en place
des sites à certains noms il y en a l
ankou aussi à la clé de saint pierre où
là il ya sept praticiens dont qui qui
est avec lequel on a signé il y a
un mois donc là pour qu'ils aient les
meilleures conditions un peu moins
coûteux par rapport à leur charge et
effectivement les médecins m'ont
beaucoup de charges trop de charges vous
rappelez vous il pique elle encore
d'impôts il faut une fois il faut
d'ailleurs que nos élites comprennent ça
le talent c'est pas de créer des impôts
c'est de créer la richesse donc surtout
priorité aux gens qui créent la richesse
par rapport aux gens qui créent des
règlements administratifs ou des
nouvelles fait je ne vous impose donc là
on le voit en tout cas c'est idem et
l'on croit donner sa contribution comme
trappe montini comme d'autres nous
parlions santé on va parler ajustement
social à présent une actualité qui n'a
pas touché uniquement département des
yvelines l'ensemble du territoire
français ces mouvements aide et gilet
jaune des mobilisations ont lieu sur le
terrain des débats vont aussi a été
organisé lors de la grande concertation
qui a suivi comment vous avez suivi et
déjà ce mouvement comme on vous l'avait
analysé ce mouvement d gilet jaune et
puis ensuite on passera à votre analyse
des réponses qui ont été apportées mais
déjà sur la contestation qui s'est
exprimée m'a aidé parce que ce sont les
impôts mais l'émission on n'est pas
normal que sur près de 200 pays on est
sur le premier pays au monde de crise
simple qu'est ce que c'est que ce qu'est
ce que c'est que ce truc mais qui a fait
ça doudou sadien qui sait que cette
culture de l'impôt de la taxe de l'état
soit soit il doit se réformer l'état on
le voit à chaque fois ils tapent sur les
collectivités qu'ils se réforment
lui-même c'est lui qui produit autant de
autant de problèmes donc je dirais il
sait il s'agit de médecins au centre des
débats je pas pour les municipales aussi
la taxe d'habitation est ce qu'on va
arrêter de toucher à ça
voilà moi je dirais que c'est le sait le
c'est le principal certainement problème
qu'on a réglé en france il faut réformer
ce périmètre de l'état il faut redonner
les compétences il faut savoir faire
travailler des gens qui sont compétents
et arrêter les procédures les règlements
les les textes où on n'en peut plus haut
fin de ces vrais du droit du travail
c'est vrai que toutes les règles sur le
droit de l'urbanisme
on peut plus rien construire tout est
paralysé enfin il ya trop de paralysie
de texte voilà mettons des gens des gens
des opérationnels
ce pays doit être gérée par des
opérationnels pas des théoriciens pas
des procéduriers pas dévoiler ce savoir
faire il a annoncé que la france sait
c'est nos ingénieurs et nos techniciens
nos chefs d'entreprises des
investisseurs qui ont fait ce pays
il faut redonner le pouvoir à ces gens
qui ont montré la valeur ajoutée qu'ils
acquis qu'ils apportent au pays c'est
crucial fondamentale et les gilets
jaunes maesa était l'émanation d'une
révolte fiscale faut pas se leurrer
quand vous êtes déjà au top et qu on
vous rajoute
le coût de l'essence surtout quand en
province où vous faites 10 20 50 km aux
imaginer sur un petit pouvoir d'achat
mais bien entendu plus plus les amendes
dues aux excès de vitesse etc
sur 81 kg bien sûr c'est pas c'est pas
c'était une révolte fiscale faut pas se
leurrer si on n'en veut pas une nouvelle
il faut changer l'élite qui dirige ce
pays je vous le dis soit vous avez mis
vous faites dans une entreprise et
produit des richesses des produits des
nouveaux produits des nouveaux services
1 qui font qu'ils font la richesse
soit vous vous mettez en retrait et vous
laisser vraiment gouverner les gens qui
ont une expérience du monde de
l'entreprise c'est fondamental ce pays
doit faire la croissance si on ne fait
pas deux à trois points de croissance
mais chez un ami ça va mal se passer en
france si on va encore avoir les
jaunards ils seront peut-être aux bleues
ou jaunes ont germé en tout cas
justement de les réponses les premières
réponses qui ont été faites par le
gouvernement quelles réponses qu'est ce
que c'est que cette mode des politiques
de dire à vous via les problèmes -
milliers de manifestants des jeux sur le
chéquier mais le chéquier c'est quoi
c'est mon chéquier qui s'offrent le
vôtre il faut un chèque de 11 à 17
milliards avec votre argent alors qu'on
est déjà un record de déficit des 28
pays de l'union européenne vous rendez
compte on est on a le plus gros déficit
on est dernier de la classe en déficit
budgétaire donc la qualité de gestion se
discute et on vous dit ah oui il ya des
problèmes on vous fait vous fait à
chaque avec quoi avec quel argent
on va créer un nouvel impôt on vous fait
un chèque et on va vous créer un nouvel
amour propre et le chèque que je vous
fait vous voulez que je vous fasse à
moins d'un mètre a dû donc il ya un
problème il faut changer cette culture
publique de la direction de ce pays
c'est plus possible de voir sable il
faut résoudre les problèmes sans créer
de nouvelles dettes ou de nouveaux
déficits ça c'est prioritaire une
confirmation qui a été fait en tout cas
c'est la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation à plus ou moins long terme
en fonction des revenus des ménages et
des foyers taxe d'habitation qui est
l'une des sources principales de revenus
si ce n'est la source principale de
revenus pour les communes pour les
agglomérations c'est forcément quelque
chose que vous n'avez pas vu
du bonnet même s'il a été prévu dans un
premier temps en tout cas d'avoir une
compensation se ressourcer en commun
avec quel argent
vous avez déjà un déficit de 82
milliards programmés doit être finances
2010 9 qui est déjà passé et plus 82
vous êtes déjà presque à 110 milliards
et on vous dit je vais vous baissez vos
impôts métal et est ce qu est ce qu est
ce que cette élite peut se retirer de ce
pays on ne veut plus entendre ça moi je
veux un type mêmes qui parlent moins
bien hein c'est pas la peine d'avoir des
mots de jouer la comédie d'avoir du
talent théâtrale on veut des gens qui
ont eu des résultats qui parlent
peut-être un peu brute un peu direct
mais revenons à des gens qui quand ils
vous donnent un chèque il est
provisionné c'est pas un chèque qui
provoque un impôt derrière quelqu'un
jours après sur votre monde voilà il
faut vraiment changer ce mode de
raisonnement c'est urgent néanmoins il
ya trop d'impôts vous l'avais dit en
tout cas il ya beaucoup de taxes pour
les foyers mais d'un autre côté il faut
pas supprimer d'impôt quelles seraient
les solutions des leviers alors d'abord
d'abord c'est de tout mettre sur la
croissance comment on fait de la
croissance
est-ce que les gens qui dirigent ce pays
ont fait de la croissance du pin
marchand écoutez saint quentin en
yvelines c'est pas moi non plus qui fait
mais on a le deuxième pib par habitant
de france après paris regardez comment
ça se passe c'est un mélange de
chercheurs sur des secteurs à forte
croissance c'est un mélange d'entreprise
de bien sûr à forte croissance qui ont
qui travaillent sur des des secteurs à
forte croissance notamment numérique le
numérique c'est le moyen de doubler la
croissance française est bas si on le
sait on met le paquet là-dessus il faut
simplifier les lois aussi à un point de
croissance à récupérer il faut il faut
faire des lois compétitive par rapport
aux autres pays il faut se réconcilier
avec le monde ou s'il faut arrêter que
la france s'isole avec des leçons de
morale je dire qu'on n'a pas de leçon de
morale à donner tous les pays
enfin les grands pays ont à peu près des
règles qui sont compréhensibles il faut
que ce monde
en tout cas reviennent à des valeurs de
bon sens on a on il ya du talent en
france mais laissons les gens de talent
et le canon c'est pas bien parler et
fait la différence sur les gens brillant
intellectuellement je suis journaliste
et les gens intelligents scénario
ference ça n'a rien à voir donc 1 1
interrogé plus les gens intelligents que
les gens brillant intellectuellement
franchement ça va ça va nous donne un
peu d'air un peu de vacances un pur pour
pour nous les collectivités qui vivons
la baisse des dotations
la ligne 18 qui disparaît des nouveaux
impôts des nouvelles texte ils font que
ça merci aller voir ce qui se prépare
les tipis pense que c'est l'état y pense
encore ces gars là que c'est l'état qui
va régler les problèmes que connaît en
france il continue à alimenter disant
rien arrêté ils n'ont pas compris alors
que c'est laisser la liberté aux gens
qui ont fait leurs preuves qui ont des
compétences réelles qui sont sur des
marchés à forte croissance et eux qui
vont nous sortir de deux des difficultés
alors puisqu'on parle politique
justement cette année aussi été marquée
par les élections européennes fin mai
début juin et en france c'est le
rassemblement national et catalyse
totalisé un peu plus de 23% qui est
arrivé premier de ce scrutin juste
devant un pour cent et quelques ados la
république en marche associé au modem
l'union de la droite et du centre n'a
obtenu que la quatrième place 8,48 % ça
c'est au niveau national un petit peu
plus dans les yvelines
comment en tant que républicain vous
avez vécu cet échec
non mais aujourd'hui vous situez vous
dans votre famille politique c'est une
baffe pour pour la gauche et la droite
traditionnelle mois passent au cash et
simplement ce qui serait bien c'est que
démolir la démocratie je sais pas si
c'est vraiment une valeur ajoutée on est
en train de démolir regarde il ya plus
d'indépendance entre
le judiciaire et l'exécutif et
législatives c'est le principe de
démocratie il n'ya plus d'indépendance
bon on le voit bien attention là en même
temps on voit aussi des de la
communication toute la journée alors par
exemple pour les européennes veut pas
lui on regarde l'impôt les élections
monsieur macron arrive bon il fait 20
millions de voix il ya 47 millions
d'électeurs il fait 20 millions de voix
très bien aux européennes il ya une
baisse de 25% nobs de la participation
c'est classique bon il n'y aurait
sûrement même si ces mêmes irlandais ne
laisse pas de vie pas si baisse pas de
25% lui il passe de 2,2 de 20 millions
de voix il passa cinq millions de voix
donc ils disent par quatre son score et
on vous dit à la presse d'état vous dis
mais c'est formidable rendez compte il a
gagné à gagner il rit du protégé du
front national car il vient d'avoir bon
mais moi je veux bien parler les choses
vraies mais la participation est valable
pour toutes les formations politiques
c'est aussi vrai pour lui il n'ya pas de
quoi quand vous passez vous êtes le
gouvernement vous êtes le parti de
gouvernement
ce que le rock c'est géré par le parti
gouvernement il faut comprendre ça donc
en plus il fait un face à face avec le
fonds nelson est en fait ils passent de
20 millions à 5 millions d'euros oui
bravo ans quel succès il à sous bon
alors écoutez je regarde moi je regarde
les deux dernières élections partielles
une dans les yvelines et une autre dans
l'hérault dans les yvelines en marche
donc monsieur macron avait fait 81% sont
candidats à la en marche il fait 31%
dans l'hérault idem le candidat en
marche
l'huile est carrément éliminé dès le
premier tour et on termine avec le ps
face au front national bon j'irai que
qu'est ce que c'est que cette
communication on vous menace quasiment
que si vous n'êtes pas avec le président
vous êtes son ennemi je vois encore
berger les le système de pressions de
menaces d'intervention si on a un effet
sur les sur les sur les élus et lui
réserve lee
jeudi le secteur des yvelines où il est
élu à l'animation c'est sacré et un
agacement des élus laissons les sons la
démocratie tranquille arrêtons les
pressions sur les élus c'est
insupportable moi j'en ai dit j'ai des
échos jo 10 rebonds voilà que chacun y
aille sous ses couleurs
voilà maintenant à priori et qu'à voir
les deux premières partiel on peut pas
dire que il ya une reproduction puis
dites moi le problème aussi c'est que si
monsieur macron se fait sans cesse élire
en présentant le front national en
créant une espèce de 2,2 pouces farouche
pas trop ce qu'il veut ce qu'il veut
montrer là dedans mais demain pour les
municipales fois ce mollet qui créé 35
mille fois elle aime le pen pour qu' il
puisse retrouver ses scores enfin même
ses scores ils sont divisés par quatre à
kessouah très bon il ya quand même il ya
quand même un sacré problème de entre
l'image de dents marche il faut que
d'abord d'abord qu'ils laissent la
démocratie fonctionne et qui laisse les
élus tranquille que chacun fasse des
listes de compétences aujourd'hui c'est
vrai que les étiquettes on va se le dire
les étiquettes bon aujourd'hui on a
besoin de gens qui ont une compétence
dans le vrai volonté quand une
expérience plus qu il na pas devenir un
vrai attrait sans étiquette
vous qui êtes candidat soit elle encore
mais moi moi ou ce est ce que j'ai
besoin et en cour d'avoir une étiquette
ces gens ne connaissent depuis votre
liste la papa pas la république mais il
y avait déjà il y avait déjà une ou deux
personnes sur la liste que te un peu
tendance en marche je vais pas les les
dires et humaniste pour ça ils sont et
c'est plutôt des gens sérieux c'est tout
mais mais il n'ya pas d'étiquette en
marche sur malicia il ya simplement des
gens qui ont des origines différentes et
des centristes
il ya deux ans marge croire yahia dlr il
ya des gens sans étiquette qui sont
quasiment majoritaire d'ailleurs les
listes aux municipales arrêtons les
politiser
je crois que c'est très différent des
scrutins nationaux présidence et
législatif c'est une chose les
municipales il n'y a pas de corrélation
des exemples que je vous ai cités
il faudra se mettre d'accord au sein de
l'agglomération pour gouverner
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines quelque fois les couleurs bleu
est ce que je veux pas dire
je crois que j'avais entendu dire qu'il
y avait des élus de l'agglomération que
cav est effectivement envisagé de
prendre quelques élus ciblées sur un ou
deux faux pas ou 75 un bon et je crois
que même à priori viennent de dc le
contraire qu'il ne souhaite pas qu'il y
ait des jeux de pouvoir et je pense que
les les douze les douze communes ne
souhaite pas jouer avec des jeux de
pouvoir ils sont prêts c'est une
gouvernance très partagés à 50 1 vous
avez dû le voir on a rarement vu durant
une période assez calme comme ça en de
gestion de 50 ans on a encore vu
standard une course qui nous a
d'ailleurs donné la meilleure note vous
le savez donc donc ça se passe bien il
n'y a pas de demande d'aller jouer avec
des jeux de pouvoir des jeux
d'étiquettes
on travaille avec la gauche entre avec
le centre contrat avec la droite ça se
passe très bien il n'y a pas de volonté
j'ai pas senti dans les 12 communes une
volonté de changer quoi que ce soit là
dessus il nous reste quatre minutes
d'émission j'aimerais qu'on parle
d'innovation qu'on parle économie pour
pour conclure celle 11.1 important pour
vous pour votre politique la politique
que vous menez sur saint quentin en
yvelines il ya eu plusieurs ouvertures
tout au long de cette année depuis
septembre dernier un campus de
l'automobile du côté de guyancourt un
campus du numérique aussi une antenne
qui a ouvert ça c'est plus pour la
formation pour les enseignants aussi est
là c'était du côté des longs cours mais
il ya plusieurs antennes sur tout le
territoire et puis là l'innovation le
rendez vous de l'innovation un petit peu
durant lequel saint quentin en yvelines
a brillé c'est le salon du bourget
récapitulatif avec nicolas landry des
taxis volant à l'énergie électrique des
avions fonctionnant avec des moteurs
hybrides des innovations présentées sur
ce salon du bourget 2019 par
l'équipementier aéronautique français
le groupe safran des technologies en
évolution permanente
on peut pas dire aujourd'hui
l'airbus a320 que vous prenez pour aller
en vacances sera totalement électrique
dans dix ans certainement pas en
revanche pour des véhicules beaucoup
plus petit donc on entend beaucoup
parler
la mobilité à la demande mais aussi des
avions comme hutter aux régionaux de
quelques dizaines de passagers et bien
des technologies pour être prête
beaucoup plus vite le projet du moteur
électrique et hybride est développée
notamment par safran tech basée à magny
les hameaux
un centre de recherche du groupe
inauguré en 2015 alors on travaille
effectivement sur comment rendre un
moteur plus électriques pour les avions
de transport de passagers
ces technologies là permettent des gains
de carburant mais aussi des gains
d'efficacité en opération des coups de
coude usage par l'électrification et
l'assistance électrique en fait du
moteur classique c'est l'incontournable
du salon du bourget le rafale l'avion de
combat de l'armée française omnirôle
développé par dassault aviation
un appareil composé de pièces fabriquées
notamment à saint quentin en yvelines
c'est le cas de cette antenne l'usiné
par le groupe bauwen et sa filiale
jacques loupé cli en collaboration avec
thales ce sont des systèmes de détection
qu'on appelle de la guerre électronique
et donc ils permettent de détecter des
cibles
pour protéger en fait tu n'auras phares
et de systèmes da nous sommes en pleine
croissance
actuellement la en l'espace de cinq ans
gwen a doublé et nous avons la même
perspective pour les 5 10 prochaines
années
au total près de 60 entreprises
aéronautiques sont implantés sur saint
quentin en yvelines pour quatorze mille
emplois dans le secteur
voilà pour ce salon du bourget qui est
un peu illustré l'innovation à saint
quentin en yvelines sur l'appui aussi
parlé de cybersécurité l'innovation au
coeur de l'action sur sur saint quentin
en yvelines notamment écouter on a on
est sécurité du futur je voulais dit
qu'ils arrivent sur saint quentin
on a déjà l'éducation du futur vous en
avez cité à tous les niveaux du primaire
jusqu'au jusqu'au secondaire jusqu'au
super jusqu'à l'université paris 7 l'est
qui va être le et mighty français qui va
être là la première université française
et celle qui rentre dans le top 20 de
shanghai mais on a bien sûr une
éducation d'éducation du futur vraiment
ici on a mais sur les emplois du futur
vous venez de démontrer de très haute
technologie à une étude qui a été faite
quand on parle d'une nouvelle qui
montrent qu'effectivement saint quentin
et la preuve plus grosses agglomérations
qui a des emplois de très haute valeur
ajoutée style style aéronautiques
défense sécurité automobile aussi donc
alors ce salon dire on a même été avec
avec olivier dassault puisqu'on pilatus
avait un groupe de 260 parlementaires à
l'assemblée
donc on était l'invité des députés
absolument a été invité par monsieur
colère qui le secrétaire général de
l'elysée un peu à propos du crédit impôt
recherche puisque en fait c'est vrai que
50 ha c'est un très beau pôle
d'excellence de recherche et et si on
veut maintenir donc ces cerveaux qui
sont sur saint quentin et sur paris
saclay il faut protéger le meilleur le
sol lui dire le meilleur produit fiscal
français le seul vraiment enviée par
dans le monde dans le monde antique qui
s'appelle le kenya pour recherche donc
on est allé voir monsieur colère ont été
reçus et les qu'olivier d'assaut la
pourrait payer en monsieur macro est
venu ici comme quoi on a des relations
avec tout le monde
nous pourrions nous salue aussi donc on
ne doit pas toucher au crédit impôt
recherche
c'est une bonne nouvelle je pense aussi
à pouvoir annoncer pour toutes aux
entreprises tous nos chercheurs qui sont
très très très très important sur 50 ha
dont vous voyez alors vous et les
transports du futur ou si vous en avez
vu le taxi volant vous avez le les
transports vous avez d'une question vous
avez la santé clients doucement
progressivement on a beaucoup de
dossiers puisque avec la notoriété qui
montrent qu'on voit de plus en plus on
nous apporte des dossiers la région
aussi un rôle très important est que
nous puisqu'on à la région n'a le
département et paris saclay qui en fait
on travaille aussi dans un moule commun
avec une très bonne une très bonne
qualité confiance je dirais qui est
importante
nouvelles saint quentin se porte bien on
va pas le dire on va pas dire le
contraire
à part bien sûr ces baisses de dotations
toutes les communes de france on les
prend aussi oui c'est pas bon mais sinon
c'est vrai qu'à des très beaux projets
vous savez demain à ont tous les jours
il ya aussi des entreprises qui arrivent
là ça se passe bien pour saint-quentin
je dirais que je vais pas partir en
vacances bientôt vraiment sûr et nous
aurons l'occasion de reparler tous ces
dossiers à la rentrée par les politiques
aussi puisque vous le savez l'année
prochaine il ya donc cette échéance des
municipales pour 2020 merci jean michel
fourgous nous avoir accompagnés pour ce
dernier cette 8ème dos de la saison
passée un très bel été sur tv 78
n'oubliez pas elle nourrit plein aux
émissions et spécial culture loisirs
sport mais aussi politique et économique
tout au long de l'été et puis rendez
vous fin août pour la reprise et des
directs
à très bientôt
[Musique]
et